One more little specific
tracking method and
this comes from the work of tracking
people, particularly their limbs and
stuff by learning their appearance and
the idea is they build a person model.
And the person model is made up
of a couple different things.
It's made up of an appearance,
we'll talk about what that is
in a minute, plus structure.
plus dynamics, allright?
Now the structure and dynamics are
generic, that is, they are the lengths
of my body, the dynamics are how
they can move so, you know,
what are the speeds people tend to move
and some of the process noise, but
the appearance is person specific,
okay, so the idea is
I'm going to learn the appearance,
and then I'm going to do the tracking.
And that's represented in
this picture here, allright?
So the idea is given some input
examples, we build the model,
and the model is, like I said,
it's generic structure, but
we might learn the colors and, you know,
the textures of these different parts.
And then, using that appearance and
the structure, we can do the detection
running, on the, on the new frames.
Here's the reference,
Ramanan, Forsyth and
Zisserman, and this is showing you
them tracking those people parts.
And the idea is they use a appearance.
That's all I want to talk
about that specific method.
A bit later actually, towards the end of
this course we're going to describe some
recognition methods that use a lower
dimensional space for doing recognition.
We've mentioned piece,
principal component analysis, et cetera.
Once we do that, we can talk about
a couple more one or two more tracking
examples that use a PCA-base description
as their appearance model but
until we have that it,
it would be premature to talk about it.